[Music]
the nft space is forever and going to be
incredible
huge the next 24 months has the
potential to be uncomfortably
volatile yeah with a very high
likelihood
of a substantial bubble burst
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
um hello crypto art land it's me second
realm aka
eric rhodes and i'm here with my guest
gary v
um aka gary vaynerchuk
and yours is much more creative as a
front-facing name i was very basic
i've had mine for about 30 years but i
just started using it in the art world
um i love that yeah so tell me
let's let's get right into it i want to
hear about your 500-foot view
of the nft space and then give me like a
prediction over the next two years where
you see things going
my overview is that it is
inevitable and will be some to me this
is not
a technology or a movement or a
social norm that kind of goes away
i think there's not a day that i live on
earth
for the rest of my life that nft is not
a conversation that is happening
similar to internet you know similar to
social networks like i just don't see
so like i i you i view the
you know the non-fungible token
blockchain realities of the
digitalization
of assets far beyond the art and
collectibles that
is so easy to understand in something
that's complicated for most
i think this obviously goes into
every transaction that's not fungible
you know so like selling a home you know
a piece of land um and many many many
many other
transactions so i think it's going to
affect the way
people launch music and books like
i myself am rethinking a very lucrative
book deal on the table for me
yeah because now i have a different path
in my head to what i would do
yeah there's digital ownership for you
right right through the entire process
correct and really like the ability to
sell the nft and then the book comes but
then i have a secondary income stream if
people are
trading the book collectible and then
the metadata of me saying well you're
part of my book club and
you know no audio book but we can do q
and a like it just changes everything
yeah one of the things that i think that
people talk about is oh
um when it comes to like the collectible
the digital collectible
and then the physical is their concern
is well what happens
uh when i get the digital the physical
collectible
and you know the digital one you know do
they have to be together and i
i think of them as like remember the old
beckett magazines with card inserts
yeah you would keep the cards you would
hold on to them as collectibles but
the magazine was in and of itself its
own physical item
i see the same thing yeah and i i and i
see i see similarities
my the way i've been explaining to
people is like look that's
the most important part of nfts for me
is does the human being or the human
beings behind a project
understand how to actually build a
community this is why i feel so
confident in it eric
right i've spent 15 years building an
actual community
and have been very thoughtful to not
monetize it in a very
inefficient silly short-term way same
thing's going to happen with me and with
nfts i will launch my own project
and that project will live with me for
the rest of my [ __ ] life
not here's a [ __ ] photo of me buy it
and i'm going to sleep
right all the metadata will be the
project not
the actual imagery or the short-term
transactional nature we'll go into that
a little bit later let me give you the
prediction so
macro view is holy [ __ ] this feels like
95 in 2005.
95 for me was cool oh my god this
internet world wide web information
super highway
this is forever i'm going to put my
liquor store on it it's going to change
my life that happened
2005 for me was you know this myspace
friendster thing
this the facebook you know oh my god
february 2006 this youtube thing
wait a minute this feels a lot cooler
than message boards
and comments in a blog hey this is
forever this is humans communicating on
top of the internet
like we do in real life this it wasn't
even social media at the time i called
it web 2.0
these web 2.0 sites they're going to
change the world
well here we are 15 years later
and we're still in the dawn of social
networks not even you know what i mean
like
yes he's had a long run inc
you know tick tock is a new club that
like so
oh right we will communicate over the
internet
right yeah e-commerce for me in 95 was
we will
shop over the internet to me
oh we will buy everything in a digital
form
over this thing called a blockchain and
you know
so to me this is a forever now the more
interesting part
in both 95 and 2005 i
saw every project that i could because
i'm that guy
and 97 of them failed
and that was hard it was hard to raise
capital and start a meaningful business
on top of these platforms
nfts are easy the ability
after you learn a little bit to mint and
put on a marketplace
anything i sold a tweet for two thousand
dollars right now on cent
this is real now because i want to learn
and what have you and feels exciting and
weird and i'm gonna work hard to make
sure that person makes a lot of money on
that tweet
if that becomes a thing but what what
i'm
petrified of eric is
i'm not as educated on the ico crash
that a lot of people in this space have
gone through because i was so
deep doing something else and i watched
proliferally and when i bought ethereum
in 16 and bitcoin and 14 i bought them
with this in mind which is this feels
right
i'm busy and don't feel like especially
because of finance like currency
doesn't speak to me i'm like i don't buy
stock like i don't like
money but i love chochkas and
collectibles and ip
yes but when i saw that i was bullish on
ethereum because i understood
you know aaron battalion big shout out
to him cto of living social big
silicon valley technologist venture
capitalist
he broke it down and i understood the
difference i was like oh okay that's
interesting about ethereum and i
understood
building on top of app ecosystem i just
kind of got it
so i was like okay i'm gonna do this i'm
not following the defy
ico thing like it felt very scary to me
the ico thing
it ended up being very scary but
i mean it's very obvious what's played
out right which was
a lot of those coins weren't right but
the macro thing
is right i think with nfps a lot more
people will be involved
every creator every artist every look at
me
i've doodled my whole life
and this is going to give me a chance to
kind of play a little bit i've been
seeing you sharing them more
and people are blown away how good i am
at them and i'm like because i've been
doing it a lot my whole life like i'm
decent
i've never thought of myself as an
artist no different
to me never thinking of myself as a
personality even though i had the gift
of gab
i just thought of myself there's a
business you have the guest a little
something
so eric here's what i would say in the
macro it's one of the biggest
technology shifts and cultural norms of
our lifetime you and mine and the people
listening
in the micro there will be a
stunning amount of people that buy
things
for investment purpose that will
collapse aggressively
on the flip side the same way in march
and april of 2000
amazon was the literally the only stock
i had ever bought
in like a five-year period probably
april probably in may or june of 2000
because what i understood was oh my god
wall street thinks the internet's a fad
everything's going to zero yeah amazon's
gonna win
even then i knew it and so i did very
well
i think the same way is that's what i'm
trying to do now
which nft projects whether it's people
whether it's punks whether it's hash
masks whether it's kitties
whether it's you know blou three loud
you know like what do i believe
in nine years is still going to matter
and that's what i spend time on when i
think about the projects
when i look at the startups that i
inevitably want to invest in
it's going to be more back to what i did
in 95 and 2005
which is you know the first three
companies i invested in in 2006 was
facebook twitter and tumblr
and i feel like i'm going to be very
similar here
where i'm confident in my first several
bets
because i'm doing a lot of homework
before i make a bet
there's two different aspects to this
there's the collectible
sort of uh piece of this where
um it's feeding sort of feeding your
your inner 12 year old when you are
shilling uh
cards at the market all that kind of
stuff and then there's the businessman
who's looking at and the investor is
looking at the companies in and of
themselves
and then there's also gary vaynerchuk
the human being
yes absolutely this piece of art is from
elise bartlett she worked
for barn she worked for me at vayner i
like her
her husband works for with me at rezzy
she's
making a big risk and going on her own
this is expensive by my
art standards i bought it because i love
her yeah i'm excited
because i'm meeting a lot of artists on
twitter and discords
i'm excited to be the humanitarian
that's how i see it
or the kind person like i'm excited to
buy art
based on i like you the human
my natural instincts around art go much
more into like what i'm doodling
which is i care about the smurfs and
punky brewster
and and max headroom and robocop
and tmt like i like those things more
than like a beautiful
you know seventies or eighties pop
culture
group pop culture guy and so i want to
do that which lens you know
which is different than seeing some
beautiful sketch or like paint
i don't like jackson pollock yeah i
don't like everybody has their own their
own artistic interests and i remind a
lot of people who are listening people
are like trying to force people to like
a certain thing
it makes me laugh like why i
i talk to i i think of myself as a coach
and a teacher i invite a lot of artists
that are new to the space come in
talk to me dm me let's let's talk about
this space they're in here for a month
and they're like
eric i'm not getting any sales and i'm
like
uh first let's think about what are you
doing well i'm just posting links on
twitter like that's you're not doing
enough
you're gonna be answering enough yeah
that's like waking up in the morning
if you're an autism hosting a link of
your art to an open c account or
whatever
that is literally like saying i've woken
up this morning
cool now what 100 yeah
my my big thing is it's community
building yeah i talk about connection a
lot uh
not community not not communicating it's
the same thing yeah yeah
exactly same exact thing and it's who is
your audience
find 20 or 30 people that are going to
talk to you gonna going to be with you
and act
and connect with you daily that's all
you need 20 or 30 people right and
and and and how much do you care about
them versus caring about you
every artist i'm talking to is like i
want to sell this for 800 bucks i'm like
what's in it for the other person
right and and there's two ways again
it's art and commerce
yeah is this something that you are
going to like
if you're doing this for collecting
flipping
with you know again and i went through
this recently with sports cards over the
last four years
nobody gets to decide what another human
being like i love how people are like
like they're trying to be dictators and
communists i'm like
i'm like i'm like you're telling me i
have to collect art for the sake of the
art and never sell it
who gave you that power i have to tell
you to look at this as an investment
where you just like
having a wallet to display who am i and
by the way i'm going to do both
but i'm going to do mine that's why i
brought up the elise thing i'm going to
support
artists that i have a an actual
connection to
from a human standpoint yes not to their
art because i've never been affected by
art that way comma
the art that i'm incredibly affected by
is character creation
like i bought magic the gathering cards
when they first came out
i like like that's what i were you into
pokemon too did you buy those guys
i was a hair at that point i'd really
started my career and i was like 100
trying to build my dad's liquor store
but my brother aj's 11 years younger and
when he got like massive strep throat
and like real sick
i went to the card store my dad bought
him a box of the original pokemon oh my
god yes
uh we always talk about that so but yes
i understand pokemon i'm obsessed with
wwf e
i understand why disney works i think
and then i care about like funny little
ones like the snorks
or the get-alongs yeah or the wuzzles
like i so i think everyone gets to pick
totally yeah and i think that's the
great thing about the nft space is
um people are going to find their own
little niche
and their own place to sell the the kind
of things that
their their people want to sell eric i
think the biggest responsibility for
people that care
during this era is getting everybody
understand it's
internet 2000. the nft space is forever
and going to be incredible huge the next
24 months has the potential to be
uncomfortably volatile with a very high
likelihood
of a substantial bubble burst from a
project level
yeah leaving 92 to 97
of things worth a lot less than you paid
for it
but leaving three to eight percent
of being probably down a little or down
some
with 17 years from now it being through
the [ __ ] roof
and that is the that to me is the sum up
of what's going to happen
in the short term i have i have a
20-year view i'm in this space as a
creator as an artist for 20 years
i'm going to ride the bubbles eric no
joke and not kidding
i am in this space for the rest of my
life on all angles as an investor of
platforms the shovels and the picks
as a collector flipper of the art
and as a creator yeah a new avenue for
you
well not really but an artist no no no
no a real one and if anybody really
follows me i've talked for years about
buying nostalgic brands because i love
ip
yeah um and if anybody's listening to me
i talk a lot about character creation
and things of that nature
i had a cartoon called little v that i
did an episode of i love this [ __ ] this
is like
a dream come true yeah for me it's like
uh my entire life has been a culmination
of
of the nft space like everything i've
learned
everything i've become you know my
interest in collecting my interest in
art my interest in tech
uh you know it's amazing mine too yeah
literally mine too yeah so you you
emigrated to
immigrated to america uh when you were a
kid you learned to speak
english with your uh watching 70s and
80s pop culture
so thinking back like 12 i because i
asked this of all my guests 12 year old
garyvee what does he think of
uh garyvee today like what's le what
does he think about him
he's he's proud that
he didn't compromise kindness
with the success that was bespoke on him
i think
the 12 year old me would be proud that
the things that my mom was putting into
my head at that point that were religion
kindness nice warmth good
is something that i've not only kept
through all the zigs and zags of my life
but now in a lot of ways what she did
for me i'm doing at a
very high level for many others
yeah i think empathy is one of the
things you talk about a lot uh
it's it's clearly showing in the way
you're approaching the space
um consciously break that down for me
because that meant
the world to me i just want to say thank
you for saying that because it means so
much to me yeah yeah
i just want to get your perspective like
what do you what are you seeing
well you're taking care to uh be mindful
about
your weight as an influencer coming into
the space but you're also
look you're bringing value to me by
jumping on my show right
i know that uh and i'm highly aware of
that very in tune to that
but you are too and that's and that's a
key aspect
of uh your your approach that i think is
so genuine
and then some people miss on uh because
they just see
whale coming in correct you know and so
like my my hope in bringing you on the
show is to show that side
um i i always
my goal for this podcast is to capture
this time and moment
in space and then in 20 years have
a tremendous amount of like content
that can be turned into a documentary
from artists that were
nobodies or somebody you know no it's
good it's it's it's a hundred percent
gonna happen 100 percent i just lived it
i like just in hotel rooms with mark
zuckerberg and
travis like i lived this exactly i
missed out on all that
i missed out on all that but i see this
moment for that i can see it yeah i see
he's got goosebumps
yeah like like you know i don't know i
know this is audio and video like
yeah it's a hundred percent gonna happen
the part that hurts to your point people
don't dig like you know what gives me
anxiety
that in 17 months or nine months when
there's a
big burst on the projects i'm gonna get
bombarded with
[ __ ] garyvee you [ __ ] c you son of
a [ __ ] snake oil salesman i'm like
[ __ ] i've been on podcast after
podcast tweet after tweet saying
macro yes micro b here's what's gonna
happen
yeah they're not [ __ ] listening and
that's ex that's what it is
it's it's it's like when you're banned
when you're when you discover nirvana
first
yeah and then they become famous and
you're mad at like
what happened oh they sold out or
something and by the way
back to empathy eric let it be known on
this podcast because i know it has an
incredible community of the ogs i think
that's appropriate i understand it
the problem is it's unstoppable what is
is going to be this like that that's why
i love the early days
like a lot of my new friends that's the
other thing
when i tell you and i'm jumping around
here a little bit my favorite part about
this
is my new friends yeah our friendship
building from this moment on
it my best buds come from that 2005
success it's those days when you're i
mean let there be no confusion no matter
how hot
it is right now on twitter and clubhouse
and discords and a little bit here and
there
98 of americans have
no concept of nfts no so we're so i
remember
in 2007 being at south by southwest and
everyone's like ah
like look it's this i'm like guys nobody
has
a [ __ ] twitter account there's 300
million
americans and at the time it was like
you know a million and every and the og
og
ogs are like oh it's over yeah [ __ ]
blows here comes the business i'm like
i'm like here comes what are you talking
about and that was like a year before
you know ashton versus cnn to get to a
million you know like
or two even so i i think
cherish these moments it won't be 2018
and 19 anymore
it just isn't no but i've been i've been
in this space for
for two years um help helping build it
from the ground up
you know being part of i think you call
the dirt right
yes um so i love and that's amazing and
those are
less what's cool about it is it's all
documented
unlike going to the first pearl jam
concert you can prove it
you've got the video provenance baby and
so
you know like one thing i've been
thinking a lot about is like you know
that
new site scent where the jack tweet is
going like i want them to have a search
function like i want i'm dying to see
the person
like this is why people don't understand
providence i
last night sleeping said oh [ __ ] i want
to see the first time bitcoin was said
on twitter what's the first single tweet
that says bitcoin
yeah and then i haven't done that yet
yeah but like
what i'm hoping is that between cent and
twitter
in their relationship if they have a
relationship if they're gonna have a
relationship
seeing that jack acknowledged them in
such a serious way yeah
imagine having the ability to search on
one of those two sites
the first time a word was mentioned
insane
in fact insane the i tried to look for
the first time i was it was another key
word but same thing right when was the
first time something
something was said so anyway it's kind
of difficult
it's gonna matter like who is the ready
here's some fun stuff this is what i say
with friends i have no idea what i'm
talking about like
do you think it's cool to know the first
person about the first ticket
to the first showing of e.t do you think
that's cool
and absolutely universally everyone's
like yes i'm like guess what
that is going to be the world yeah
exactly we're going to be able to see
and and uh you know for collectors and
it's going to be
who the who the wallets that content has
passed through
are you kidding it's the greatest thing
ever i would buy right now
a collectible that randy the macho man
savage once held
right 100 yes
like i don't people don't understand how
social currency works
it's why you're wearing the beard that
you're wearing right now totally
it's why people buy people like gary i
don't get nfts i'm like you have a gucci
bag
they're like yeah i'm like that's nft
he's like what do you mean i'm like
why'd you buy that right you're flexing
you're
socially communicating and it works both
ways i love when
hipsters i have so many hipsters they're
friends they're anti-established i'm
like that's your version
you don't buy a polo you buy a vinyl
record it's all the same game eric
well nfts are kind of counterculture
anti-establishment right
you know and this goes to why i think
what i'm spending all my time on
is is it crypto punks is it pepe on
bitcoin their first block like is it
kitties is it like
like what really establishes itself
as the og projects that that has
christie's and sotheby's and
the billionaire and millionaires of the
future wanting to own
that's a that's not about the people
like i love when i tell people like
that's
not about the money that's about the
clout
of was i smart enough to play chess
and figure it out
totally uh from from a scarcity
perspective so let me let's let me throw
this at you
you know card collectors we think about
the 52 mantles the 51 mantles they're
the
they're the [ __ ] gold standard in uh
you know
or used to be the gold standard in you
know
the card collecting community 68 ryan
right you know these kinds of things
they're scarce because they're low
production
and kids used to throat my dad used to
put mantles in in the wheels of his car
and the bike to make the flipping
right 80s and 90s overproduction of
baseball cards uh
other collectibles what attributes are
you looking for in terms of scarcity
for digital collectibles well it's funny
80s and 90 what people always forget
always
and i couldn't believe how many people
didn't get this part with cards in the
last four
years yeah supply doesn't scare me
supply scares me
when it outpaces demand yeah people are
so
fixated they're like gary i'm gonna
crush it's a one-of-one i'm like
if zero people want it you've got a
problem
got air right so like that's such a
right
there's a lot of blue slaggletooths that
were in the sears cantina set
only there's just a lot more star wars
nerds that want that one than the red
one that was on an empire star strikes
back card
hence it's worth more right it's not
like
it's not like star wars only made one
yak face power the
like there's like migos on cards from
the 70s action figures like
you don't need there to be one in
existence or 19 or 57.
this is my point with michael jordan and
charizard michael jordan rookie and
charizard
are the next 40 years of net worth
individuals
holy grail the end yeah and that's
and so what am i looking for it with
with you know i'm looking for enough
i mean look i i've alluded to it enough
i'm extremely bullish on crypto punks
because i think it's og og
yeah i think it's 8-bit culture i think
people underestimate the
visual attachment to 40 and 50-year-olds
that have wealth
yeah and i think that there's only i
think 10 000 with
you know and so like that's that's
that's a good
starting point like it's established drc
like it basically became
kind of like the thing that everyone
pointed to and built on top of
absolutely they they basically uh were
the reason the erc721 token
was created it was it's for them just
think about that
yeah right and then culturally
significant technologically
significant enough people give a [ __ ]
about it
there's only a certain amount it's got
all the things that make you realize
like they built it in a way
they're too very nice got men i think
that matters yeah you know like they're
part of the community
um and i think they built it in a way
that people care like they care about a
purple hat like literally i care about
purple hats because
actually because of the hat i'm wearing
i own the esports team called version
one with the owners of the minnesota
vikings
yeah and like we wear purple hats like
like it's just like i don't know like
it's not super complicated
and like the earrings and the vr like so
i'm trying to find things like that
hash masks is something i haven't dug
into yeah but the cryptic nature of the
things you can't see
and clearly interesting that's
interesting correct it's
interesting and then look i do think
that there'll be
things that come along like that have
been around pokemon's official official
nfp official official nft project is
gonna matter
sure yeah classic ip coming in will
always have
a uh have a place in in our hearts
a hundred percent and new ip like the
next star wars pokemons
yeah you know and star tracks are going
to be built
starting with nft yeah i know that i
know that we're at
uh the half hour uh if you got one more
minute
one more minute i did push the 1203 so i
got that minute go yeah cool so
i don't know if you noticed but i
started a project called unofficial
punks
which was like this social community um
and really what i want to tell you about
it is uh
it's it's exciting to me to see people
who
i've been priced out of buying a punk
who can now still participate and that's
the community aspect that i really
really like to push and share um and
it's
you know what's cool about that right
eric it speaks to counter culture right
hunks were authentic then they became
too big then you you know how i see that
like rock and roll
the rolling stones were super authentic
yeah their concerts got expensive
here comes the clash yes right and and
that's what i
and and i think that's amazing and by
the way
they both co-ex i hate that people want
everything to be
or right there's a there's an end in
this space for everything yeah
i think the word and if this space can
fall in love with the word and
i think that you'll see a lot more
happiness and i'm hoping to be a
champion of that word in this space
yeah well thank you so much for watching
thank you so much brother i wish you
well
yeah youtube watcher what's up it's
garyvee first of all thank you so much i
hope you're doing super well during
these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you